Joseph L or Curtiss three Manuel
Schaefer says that in Germany Russian
automaker Lada is mainly known for its
off-road vehicles like the neva but the
Gerda shows that Lada can do more
Lada is the passenger car division of
Ottawa's the biggest car maker in Russia
and Eastern Europe Amana was taking the
Granta subcompact out for a spin he says
at the moment there's just one engine
available for the gonta it has an output
of 64 kilowatts or 87 horsepower which
might not sound like a lot but a Manuel
says two factors make it feel quite
lively one is the cars low carb weight
even if you add 80 kilos for the driver
it tips the scales at just 1080
kilograms
the other factor is that the engine has
1.6 liters of cubic capacity giving it
enough power to zip along nicely the car
accelerates from 0 to 100 kilometers an
hour in 11.8 seconds but what's most
impressive about the Granta is its price
in germany a base model costs just under
7,000 euros our test car which can run
on LPG also known as propane sells for
9600 euros
then Amana world doesn't find the
interior that attractive
there's too much hard plastic though in
this price range they have to cut
corners somewhere on the positive side
it's all very tidy there's an ordinary
radio which you can switch on and set to
the station you want to hear without
working your way through tons of menus
that's user friendly however the radio
is an option that costs extra to the
tune of 200 euros you mind well finds
the Granta suspension is just average it
provides good cushioning on uneven
routes but the driver can really feel it
when going over big bumps or potholes
sometimes even making the dashboard
creak and groan but he says you can live
with that by turning up the radio a bit
louder and louder
emanuelle thinks it's too bad there's no
climate control system available at any
price there's a rear window defroster
though which comes in handy in the
winter for mother that's deflectors
what's more the rear window defroster
comes as standard even in the base model
during his test-drive average fuel
consumption was just over 7 liters per
100 kilometers amanda says that's a
little over the manufacturers official
figure of 6.6 liters but it's still okay
though for 2,350 euros extra you can
order a Ganta which also runs on LPG or
propane saving you money at each Philip
our tester says there's not Oh de
l'espace in the back but it's roomy
enough he can fit two fingers between
the seat and his knees and says if
you're not over one meter 80 you should
fit in just fine though the seat back is
pretty hard for long hauls then these
are just fun seamless hard now he's
going to look at the trunk in weather
like this it's too bad you can only open
it with the key or the button located
under the steering wheel once open
emmanuelle is impressed with a spacious
trunk he says even his tripod case which
is often problematic fits in easily
great but overall the grantors greatest
feature is its price keeping that in
mind makes it easier to tolerate the
car's lack of extras and creature
comforts when it comes to making a cheap
entry-level car Lada is miles ahead of
the competition
you